that's my bosses how it is there was a
Harvard or your dork and the women
aren't the best looking every sets up
it's like one of these things that
comics do where you say something like
real dark just your comic friends and
they're like you should do the on stage
and it's like this challenge of like oh
right you are he goes on stage at the
comedy connection in Fanueil Hall anyway
I don't remember the exact word of it 50
people but you were like you know the
problem with Boston is women are just
really not that good-looking people like
I love that training and now I can go
after a crowd and just like you can go
with maybe one I'm being honest yeah you
know training yeah yeah the way and that
that you can see that in like in like
Katt Williams when he's [ __ ] on
Michael Jackson when he was still a hero
yeah and there was like boo goes [ __ ]
you I'm children [ __ ] you he's a
molester yeah you know that go right at
them I don't care how you feel I'm well
justified in this super justified with
that yeah I mean that was just some so
as I bought some women are disgusting
even if they're good-looking their
voices of garbage bag oh [ __ ] me and my
[ __ ] yeah man you [ __ ] queer those
were fun times to men because like when
we first started going on the road
together like one of the more fun things
was well it was really fun hanging out
and doing shows but it was also fun
saying like you can't get fired
check apart dude that was such an
influential time my stand that's
specifically where it was like we're at
the hotel 5-minute walk from Fanueil
Hall hey let's get high I was like nom
about the four-month stage a crazy
kicking high right now that's where I've
been high 20 times maybe right and
you're like why I'm like because I won't
do good egos so I'm like what do you
mean so I guess so I think but then it
goes you won't get fired didn't hire you
you can't play here it's 40 50 seats and
also like it gets too far for you to go
to feature and you just way too big for
you to headline so I'm hiring you and I
don't care if you get too [ __ ] up
so it's more pot and it's like yeah we
also wanted you to feel free and that
there's these moments when you get high
and you go on stage where and they don't
always happen but there are moments
where you take a right turn into
brilliant Vil mmm and that right turn
doesn't exist sometimes if you're sober